[موسيقى]
السلام
عليكم اسمي محمد مصور فوتوغرافي من
البصره طبعا التصوير الفوتوغرافي بال
الاونه الاخيره صار اسلوب حياه عند البعض
فما يمر يوم بدون ما تصور بدون ما نستخدم
الكاميرات
ف الكل عندها هواتف نقاله وهاي الهواتف
النقاله بها كاميرات
رقميه طبعا نستخدمها يوميا هاي الكاميرات
نستخدمها للعمل للتوثيق لامور العائله
اليوم يمكن مليت الفونات كلها
صور البعض حب يحصل على صور احسن ففكر
يشتري كاميرا
احترافيه كان يظن انه هاي الكاميرا
الاحترافيه راح تنطيه صور
احترافيه لكن السؤال اللي
نطرحه هل الكاميرات الاحترافيه تصنع منا
مصورين
محترفين للاسف وبنسبه كبيره لا لان
الكاميرا وحدها ما تسوي هذا الشيء اكو
نقاط مهمه اغلب المصورين الشباب يهملها كل
ظل الكاميرا راح تخلص كل شي لكن هاي
النقاط هي السبب الرئيسي اللي توصلك انه
تكون مصور وتحصل الصور اللي كنت تبحث عنها
النقاط
هي الهدف الهدف يعني انا اليوم من اريد
اشتري كاميرا لازم اكو ببي هدف انا شنو
اريد اصير اريد اصير مصور عالمي اريد اصير
مصور محلي لازم اكو سبب انا اصرف هاي
الاموال وخاصه الكاميرات الاحترافيه غاليه
جدا النقطه
الثانيه اللي هي الشغل الشغف هو اللي يوقد
نار الابداع اللي بداخلنا هو اللي يدفعنا
وينطي الجراه نحلم باشياء البعض يشوفها
مستحيله والبعض يشوفها بعيده جدا لكن
بجنون الشغف يخلينا كل شي نقدر
نسويه النقطه الثالثه اللي هي الجهد انا
اليوم من اريد اصير مصور لازم ابذل طاقه
ابذل جهد يعني مو يكفي انه انا والله ذكي
انا عبقري انا اعرف بالتصوير خلاص اعرف كل
شي لازم ادرس
اقرا اشوف دروس على على اليوتيوب اطور
معلوماتي حتى اوصل للمستوى اللي اريده
وبنفس الوقت ارجع احقق الهدف اللي حطيته
بالبدايه فبدون هاي النقاط الكاميرا ما
راح تسوي
شي تجربتي ويا التصوير ابتديت التصوير
منتصف
2013 بعد ما تخرجت من الجامعه طبعا تصوير
ما يبتل اي شي من درا دراستي بس من تخرجت
من الجامعه كان عندنا وقت هواي نمليه
بالدراسه خلصت الجامعه اجا الملل اجا
البيت اج الوقت الزايد اللي ما تدري وين
توديه بذك الفتره كانوا اصدقائي اغلبهم
يصورون فقلت خلي اجرب التصوير بديت اصور
بالموبايل اغلب الناس تبدا من الموبايل
صورت يوم بعد
يوم حبيت التصوير قمت انشر الصور
بالفيسبوك كنت اسمع ردود ايجابيه ومرات
سلبيه بس انا بصوره عامه حبيت
التصوير فبعد فتره قررت اشتري
كاميرا بحثت هواي بالانترنت وطبعا الفضل
كان الصديقي الحسن هو اللي كانت عنده
كاميرا وحببني بالتصوير وقلت خلاص اشتري
كاميرا فبحثت هواي بالمواقع الى ان وصلت
النتيجه انه اشتري هاي الكاميرا هاي
الكاميرا تعتبر من الفئه الادنى
بالكاميرات الاحترافيه يعني كاميرا جدا
بسيطه لكن كبدايه بديت
بها بديت اصور اكثر ظليت اطلع للشوارع
للانهار للناس الكبار نصورها وبعدها بديت
اشترك ب معارض محليه ف قلت انا خلاص صرت
مصور عده
ايام بديت احس بركود ماكو شيء جديد انا كل
يوم نفس الصور نفس المستوى فقلت انا لازم
اطور من روحي فحبيت اشوف شنو صاير
بالتصوير العالمي جاني هذا الفضول رحت على
الانترنت دورت كان القى موقع اسمه ال 500
بي اكس اول مره اشوف
هذا الموقع يعتبر اكبر موقع بالعالم مختص
بالتصوير بالمصورين به اكثر من 7 ملايين
مصور بين هاوي
ومحترف لكن الصدمه انا من فتحت هذا الموقع
شفت الاعمال اللي بهذا الموقع يعني من
الخيال اعمال على مستوى فعلا عالمي ف
باوعت الصوري انا مو مصور يعني انا شلون
انا كنت اقول انا مصور انا مو مصور
ف اجاني تساؤل انه هذول شلون صاروا هيك
يعني هو الموضوع موضوع معدات
وامكانات ماديه وسفر وطلعه ويحصل هاي
الصور لو اكو شي ثاني فرجعت من جديد كانما
انا مو
مصور
بديت ابحث من جديد بالانترنت عن دروس
مجانيه لان هنا ماكو فد شخص يعلمك تصوير
موجود بالبصره الا ما ندر فحبيت اعلم روحي
بروحي بديت من البدايه رحت على الانترنت
لقيت الاف مئات الالاف مو بس الاف من
الدروس المجانيه فاستغلت يوم بعد يوم
اسبوع بعد اسبوع كل يوميه اشوف دروس بعده
لغات عربي انجليزي ف مر اسبوع اسبوعين
ثلاثه حسيت جاي اتحسن قمت من اصور واباوع
الصور القديمه اقول انا شلون كنت انشر هاي
الصور فهذا كان اكبر دليل انه انا جاي
اتطور
بعدها صورت اكثر شاركت بالهاي المعارض
المحليه من جديد
وفجاه اجي على بالي انه اتخصص فد محور
محور غريب نوعا ما على البعض هو محور
الفاين ارت هذا المحور المصور يصور عده
صور باماكن مختلفه بمدن مختلفه بظروف جويه
مختلفه بليل بنهار يجمع هاي الصور اللي
تطلع من كاميرته
ويركبه بشكل يخلق فد مشهد حالم مشهد مو من
الواقع مشهد يكون يصور من خياله وافكاره
الخاصه بحيث منشوف ه المتلقي تاخذ العالم
ثاني عالم وهو ما شايفه ما
عايشه اراويكم هذا الفيديو اللي هو يختصر
هذا
[موسيقى]
الموضوع هذه الصور كلها طلعت من كاميرتي
يعني هذا الفرق بين الفاين ارت وبين
التصميم او الديجيتال ارت اللي هو المصور
ياخذ الصور من الانترنت او من مصورين
ثانيين او ياخذهم من مواقع اللي اسمها
ستوك اللي توفر الصور المجانيه هاي الصور
كلها طلعت من كاميرتي الخاصه بعد افكار
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ودراسه طبعا الاعمال مبنيه على فكره الاهم
من الصور انه لازم ترسم الفكره قبل الصور
بعدها تجمع الصور بعدها تركبها بالصوره
الاحترافيه هاي الصوره من اكثر الصور اللي
نجحت بهذا المحور فازت سنه 2013 بجائزه
سينا الايطاليه اللي تعتبر من اهم الجوائز
على مستوى
اوروبا كرر النجاح هاي السنه وفازت جائزه
السفاره البريطانيه عن افضل صوره
بالعراق الاعمال اللي شفتوها بالفيديو هي
السبب اللي وصلتني للعالميه يعني بعد ما
نشرت هاي الاعمال بدات اعمالي تتصدر
الموقع اللي هو اكبر موقع بالعالم اللي
يحتوي 7 ملايين
مصور بعد ما تصدرت الموقع بدات اداره
الموقع تركز علي بعد فتره صنفت ني ضمن
افضل مصورين العالم بهاي
الفئه
و وبعد فتره اشهر صنفني الموقع افضل مصور
فاين ارت
بالعالم بعدها صار عندي حافز انه اكتب
دروس ومقالات بهذا الفن اللي ما اللهه
ماده هواي على الانترنت لان الكل مصور
يحتفظ باسراره حبيت اشاركها للعامه بديت
اكتب دروس هاي الدروس نشرت باهم المواقع
المختصه بالتصوير مثل 500 نفسهم ومثل بيتا
بيكسل بعدها فتره راسلتني احدى المجلات
الاسكندنافيه ونشرت لي درس كامل خطوه
بخطوه بعدها صارت الصدمه بالنسبه الي شركه
ادوبي فوتوشوب نشرت احد دروسي على مواقعها
الرسميه اثناء النشر كان عنوان جدا مميز
من شركه فوتوشوب مو انا اللي كاتبه هم
اللي كتبوه محمد ستار لا يلتقط الحقيقه هو
يصنع احلام وفعلا الصور كانت
احلام فكانت هاي اكبر دافع اتلقاه بذك
الفتره انه الشركه المصنعه لبرامج التعديل
تنشر لك ه الصور وبهيك عناوين مميزه
استمريت بعد
بدات المواقع المنافسه لل 500 بي اكس
مواقع رئيسيه عالميا مثل الوان اكس والاف
ستوبر تنشر لي هاي الصوره نفسها نشرت من
قبل البي بي سي
بعدها اشتركت بمعارض دوليه هواي منها
بامريكا بكندا باستراليا بجنوب افريقيا
تركيا وبلدان ثانيه
اوروبيه بعدها نشرت لي عده مجلات بعض
الاعمال بعض الدروس منها الديجيتال فوتو
منها السن منها ماستر كلاس كاميرا بيكسو
وعده مجلات ثانيه ما موجوده على
الشاشه
بعدها ابرمت عقد مع شركه امريكيه متخصصه
بتسويق الاعمال عالميا وبنفس الوقت قبل
هالشي انا بعت عده اعمال الاغراض تجاريه
واغراض الاقتناء
الشخصي هذ الانجازات كلها اللي صارت اللي
شفتوها من خلال هاي الكاميرا البسيطه اللي
هي ارخص من موبايلات بعض
الحضور
يعني الفنان مو ضروري تكون عنده معدات
احترافيه بعد فتره
العفو بعد فتره استهواني محور مختلف كليا
يعني لايم التركيب ولاي من الصور الجامده
محور يريد شجاعه اكثر شلون هاي المنصه انه
لازم تكون شجاعه حتى توقف عليها فهذا
المحور هو محور تصوير
الناس يعتبر من اكثر المحاور صعوبه
بالعالم يحتاج مهارات خاصه بهاي الفتره
قررت اغير كاميرتي لان ديش كاميرتي قالت
لي كافي فاشتريت هاي الكاميرا تعتبر من
الفئه ما فوق الادنى يعني بعدها كاميرا
بسيطه لكن بها متطلبات تقنيه تساعد بهذا
النوع من
التصوير تصوير الناس يحتاج فد مهارات خاصه
مهارات تواصل انساني بحيث تقدر تتقرب
للشخص اللي تريد الصوره تقدر تنفتح على
مشاعره على تفاصيل حيات على مشاكله تتقرب
له اكثر حتى تقدر تستخرج اكبر مقدار من
المشاعر وتعكسها بصوره ليش بعض الصور تكون
مو حلوه صور الوجوه السبب المشاعر ما
موجوده ف تحتاج شجاعه من المصور حتى يتقرب
للناس اللي يصورها صارت لي تجربه طبعا
بتجارب انسانيه لطيفه جدا محور تصوير
الناس صارت لي تجربه قبل سنتين كنت اصور ب
مدينه السماء
فصورت طفل عمره سن 12 سنه ممكن هيك كان
ف بعد مرور سنتين رحت لنفس المكان فهو على
بالي انا ما انسى اللي اصوره مريت على نفس
الرصيف وكنت انتظر اريد اشوفه فجاه التفتت
لقيت يلعب وياي اطفال فصحت باسمه التفت
علي اول مره ما اعرفني طفل هواي علي سنتين
من تمر عليه بس من شاف كاميرتي اج ركض علي
سلم علي وقاللي يصورني وصاح اهله سلموا
علي وضيفوني ببيتهم يعني مجرد صوره خلقت
لي قصه وصداقه مع طفل ودامت الصداقه
سنتين واكثر من سنتين انا اتوقع اذا اروح
لنفس المكان ان شاء الله اشوفه فتصوير
الناس
برساله عميقه جدا المصور الفرنسي جين لو
جودارد يقول عندما تقوم بتصوير وجه ما
فانك تلتقط الروح مت بئه خلفه يعني مو
مجرد صوره اكو اشياء اكبر ورا الصوره راح
تشوفون هاي الاشياء بهاي الاعمال هذه
الصوره فازت بجائزه الامارات العربيه
المتحده سنه
2016 كررت الانجاز وفازت هاي السنه جائزه
الشارقه
2017 هاي صوره ثانيه تقدرون تشوفون هاي
كميه المشاعر اللي بصور وجوه الناس
والرساله اللي تطلع من عندها
بعد مرور
سنه قررت امضي اكثر بهذا المحور حبيت اكثر
من التركيب للعلم التركيب وصلني للعالميه
بس هذا حسيت به رساله رساله انسانيه فقررت
انه اخذ مشاريع اكبر استبدلت الكاميرا
خذيت كاميرا مواصفات اعلى هاي تعتبر من
الفئه فوق
المتوسطه يمكن اذا لاحظتوا انه الكاميرا
ما بها عدسه امكانات الماديه ما سمحت لي
اشتري كاميرا وعدسه اشتريت الكاميرا وعاده
استعير عدسات من صديقي عصام او احمد ما
موجود هنا فما وقفني هالشي الكاميرا وهسه
انا شغال على مشروع ضخم جدا ان شاء الله
يكمل بال 2017 مشروع
عالمي بالاخير اقول النوعيه وليست الكميه
يعني اصور 12 صوره خلال سنه كامله صوره
عالميه تنجح توصل للعالم افضل مما اصور
365 صوره الناس تشوفها هسه تها باك شكرا
z